et paris paris et c'est le bassin de la
villette pris par le gène
les écluses immobilisé
c'est le canal saint-martin qu'on
traverse à pied sec mais le froid s'est
enfin apaisé et sur les lacs du bois de
boulogne
la foule parisienne est venue patiner
la célèbre cascade transformer en
stalactites a recommencé à couler
pendant qu'en même temps dans tout paris
les gouttières engorgé se sentent éprise
d'un regrettable esprit limitation
et si l'on cherchait la chaleur dans les
rues on en a eu aussi qu'on n'avait pas
cherché
et pendant que le charbonnier devenait
le héros du jour
le commerçant en réfrigérateur se
promettait de fermer boutique
dans ce pari qui ne se réchauffer tout
de même que lentement
les amoureux avaient toujours leur place
au pied d'une horloge comme à l'habitude
mais l'amour ne résiste pas toujours ni
à trop de froideur ni à 30 froid et il
ne faut pas trop lui en vouloir